[Music]  dating in Hollywood is literally the  worst thing  just days after Scott Disick traded  Bella Thorne for his ex Chloe Bartoli it  seems Bella is going back to her former  flame to Gregg Sulkin  who is your celebrity crush Grey silk'n  yep here's the steamy and shirtless snap  Bella posted on Instagram Monday in  honor of Greg's 25th birthday she gushed  in the caption I love you always been  such a wonderful person glad we are here  through thick and thin I just got lucky  this all comes on the heels of the 19  year old actresses recent trip to can  with Scott Disick after Scott and Bella  pact on the PDA the 34 year old reality  star was photographed getting cozy with  another woman  Khloe Bartoli the drama seemingly  prompted Bella to tweet that the can  life isn't for me and I'm not talking to  Scott or anyone else do you think Bella  and Gregg's former romance could be  heating up again tweet us at ET now  [Music]  you